right Dean what do you think aliens look
like they're sad because they think that
we don't like them it really depends on
how long they've been evolving that's an
alien there's no right answer since no
one really knows but we often imagine
extraterrestrials to look a certain way
because we've encountered them in books
films or on TV shows which means that
when we think about aliens we're usually
thinking about the product of someone
else's imagination this is the first
film featuring life out in space a trip
to the moon by georges milies it came
out in 1902 and the strangemoon aliens
in it are not at all that strange they
actually look a lot like us these
creatures were incredibly ambitious at
the time but they were also convenient
even the practicality of having be
needing someone to play it you know this
is Charlie Henley an oscar-nominated
visual effects supervisor who worked on
Ridley Scott's alien series so yeah he
spends a lot of time thinking about
aliens good okay so they got an end up
with a head and arms and legs impact
sense the idea that they would relate to
us if they're intelligent so be kind of
similar but everyone sees it we don't
have any reason to believe that they
would look anything like us the form of
a human being is the result of several
billion years of evolution there's no
reason to believe that the development
of life would be so similar as it was on
earth that the sort of the form of life
would would look anything like we have
on earth that's Andrew Simeon the
director of SETI Institute where they
conduct experiments to detect
extraterrestrial technology we're lucky
in that we don't have to think too much
about the biological organism the
specifics of the life that created the
technology because we just search
directly for the technology and then we
use that
a proxy for the existence of life but
imagining alien organisms especially
ones with relatable features is what
feeds a popular theme in science fiction
the relationship between us and them
there's always a point of contact an
interaction that sometimes hostile and
other times it leads to a warm and fuzzy
relationship and that's made for some
powerful storytelling are they good or
are they bad what would we do if they
try to communicate with us science
fiction has stuck around as a major
Hollywood genre for decades with more
advanced visual effects technology in
recent years filmmakers had more room to
experiment with the alien form but even
with the right tools it can be hard to
break out of what we already know
normally history for the film because
some DNA that you want to follow for
example the the knee morph in the new
alien is affected really like a new
creature that really wanted to create
that it had the DNA of the original
alien
so obviously features that relate to
that that connection creates a strong
sense of nostalgia for franchise like
alien but sometimes when creators break
away from that DNA that leads to new
forms in the edge of tomorrow
there's a crazy-cool to mimic and we did
some design work for The Heretic brother
brief for that was ocean the humanistic
obviously and actually follow the normal
laws but the challenge with anything my
lies but if it doesn't follow rules the
wheel idle and it's hard to sell it as
something really tangible they need to
come up with something totally new but
also have it makes sense to us
often the trick is to find inspiration
in major examply the name was we
reference these goblin sharks which are
quite rare found in the deep sea and
they and they have a particular quality
to the skin but also just the mechanism
of how their mouths open or the ink
squirting hepta pods in arrival their
otherworldly but still familiar and even
group from guardians of the galaxy
respectively lady and you know not in
any classical sense like he's kind of
made out as a like made out of tree the
design brief there is to make him
friendly but also to figure out the
technicalities and powers in a work
these aliens come from someone else's
imagination and they might not be
entirely rooted in science but the
depictions make us think about life
beyond our planet where we're all sort
of wondering about about the same thing
and I think some people draw pictures of
it and some people make movies about it
and some people make music about it and
some people talk to their friends and
family and some scientists try to to
determine the answer using the
principles of basic science and
observational astronomy but it's all
part of I think the same human question
which which is of course are we alone
[Music]
you